excellent so basic details out of the
way the next thing we are looking for
are about speed acceleration distance
but the maximum right so let's have a
look at this see so maximum speed and
workout maximum speed is that come from
I've kind of already differentiated
enough times haven't I I only two
tangents is enough there's my velocity
function right there ok so I want this
to be the largest it possibly can be
right where does that come from it comes
from surely it comes from the amplitude
of the velocity function right like
that's when the boss c function is
highest and lowest i'm looking for speed
that's just the 92 the absolute value of
it ok so therefore maximum speed is
going to be I'd have to wear that sign
right what am I going to get it's just
going to be full and I have units music
starttls having a bad day today okay rub
maximum speed tell me what to look for
next maximum acceleration now remember
how we found maximum speed by looking at
the velocity function and just looking
at the extremities that's a lovely
predictable thing about all of these
trig functions no don't tell me about
stationary points just tell me about the
extremes of these right so in exactly
the same way I'm gonna look at X double
dot there is right there okay I don't
care which where is facing I just want
to know the biggest value hey what is it
now they said maximum we know that speed
is a scalar it doesn't worry about
direction acceleration is in to scale it
actually does the sign cards matter so
therefore if I'm looking for yes it's a
vector if i'm looking for a maximum then
which is being a full pie or negative 4
pie for players bigger isn't it I don't
think that's really the intention of the
question though they're looking for just
they really aren't any that makes you
but I don't think there's a nice neat
word that we look at which is just
acceleration without blame outside I
really say that negative pulp I is like
more than 4 pie because it's like you
like it looks really just accelerated
into the opposite direction that's
correct yeah so that's where we're
trying to be we're trying to be specific
in particular with whether we're worried
about direction or not but when you see
like when they're talking about maximum
they're clean not really that worried
about which direction your face because
again it's a symmetrical situation your
other persian that way well that way and
if you're just worried about the size of
it then that's the number so don't don't
worry about direction in the context
really of maximum and lastly the maximum
distance from the origin now maximum
distance I believe we've kind of already
answered this haven't we it's the
amplitude in this case the amplitude of
the displacement function is exactly the
maximum distance from the origin so I
would just say foreign pi meters but
think with me in what cases with the
amplitude and maximum distance not be
the same okay uh hold on second so I can
I could have a different starting point
right for example kassadin extreme
aggression but I'm still have been doing
the same thing I'm still locked between
the same now do you realize what he's
gonna say Darcy wanna goes out very good
sir if I say okay I'm going to start 100
meters up here okay the amplitude tells
you how far away you want from that
censored versions you're waving around
up here okay but the distance for the
origin is at this huge distance so what
would you actually say in that case if
for example of my center of motion
there's naught x equals 0 for x equals
100 last interview learnline yeah it
would be now de pena lets us draw a
picture shall we here's my beautiful to
scale diagram of where a hundred is
there's my center of motion okay and
what is my hunky beautiful scale what I
mean what's for an pie it's a bit over a
bit over one
okay that's the best scale okay now in
this case being at my center of mission
is in a positive direction okay to get
the maximum distance do i add us to i
subtract i add right 100 plus 4 pi yeah
hundred plus we'll fight that's really
bad but if I were to move my Center
aggression in the negative direction ok
so now this is seven eight hundred okay
so here's my motion isn't that beautiful
and simple and harmonic um am I going to
add four pyar am I going to subtract sir
okay you think about distance aren't you
don't think you're our distance ok now
just numerically if you're freaking
about the vectors right to get to this
furthest place is a displacement it
should be this no it says distance if I
say okay where am I not just how far but
where am I this is negative 100 to get
to the bottom of motion there it's [ __ ]
900 takeaway for on pipe clearly you're
trying to get lower okay but this is a
question about distance how far is that
from the origin hunch post for Mike
right because you're just thinking about
measuring that way you measure 100 you
don't care about positively you and then
you measure a little bit more fall apart
that's it's a hundred plus form point
yeah she also get a different distance
so that happens you to the function if
they said like oh within this specific
time and it just doesn't get to the pink
color correct yeah if we were to put
some kind of restriction on the domain
then your maximum distance would be
dependent on will do I ever actually
take a value that gets me to the extreme
aversion or not I will point out in
simple animation that's very unusual
because the whole point about it is that
it does the same thing in forever okay
but there's no reason why the car